madame tienne qu'est-ce que tu fais là
j'attends toujours la réponse de Harvard
je venais voir si vous aviez des
nouvelles Gérard allô vous voulez lui
offrir une bourse je vous tiens au
courant c'est pas drôle
t'as jamais eu l'impression mais qu'on a
un peu gâché notre jeunesse tu voudrais
faire quoi
ils vont au bowling ils vont à des fêtes
et des fêtes
et les conditions de ma proposition ce
sera un honneur et laisse l'autre tu
oublies
aux garçons c'est le paradis ce qu'il
faut c'est que ce qu'il te faut c'est
une lettre de recommandation
extraordinaire capitale
[Applaudissements]
qui est diplômé de Harvard en résumé on
va improviser une rencontre avec le mec
le plus populaire de l'école dans une
soirée on n'est pas invité étant
enchaîne en lui demandant un service
ça va ben pourquoi ça irait pas
j'aurais jamais dû venir on doit juste
trouver Graham dans le signe qui
de
CRIP vive le bouledogue quoi
vive les boules
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé si tu en avais besoin je
pourrais te donner des cours ce serait
un peu une façon de m'excuser
grave
va tout de suite mettre un t-shirt ta
professeur est arrivé
vraiment que j'étais un abruti et toi
alors est-ce que tu savais qui j'étais
pourquoi tu as voulu m'aider
[Musique]
la plupart des gens viennent me voir en
espérant que je puisse leur être utile
je veux plus continuer à être paralysé
et laisser passer toutes les occasions
[Musique]
quelle sera ton plus grand regret
comment vous savez qui c'est d'abord